[Music]
I'm Adrian Graham I'm a cloud solutions
architect for media and entertainment at
Google based in Los Angeles I spent
about 20 years in visual effects at
different VFX houses around the world
working on pipelines basically writing
the glue that ties together proprietary
and custom applications so today sharing
the stage with Rihanna : my name is
Deanna can work for elastica where I get
to play with a lot of cool toys in media
rendering and stuff so yeah working with
the partners and Google is a major one
for us I'm French so I won't be able to
hide the accent I've been in the media
industry through several you know
companies with storage and backup an
archive you know software so pretty
pickle space and super happy to be here
we've been working in the past few
months with Vilna Gaon MO and building
some cool stuff they will see ya at the
end yeah what you're gonna see today is
so because I come from a the effects and
animation background we're going to it's
a it's very interesting workload as a
way to to pressure test and really push
the boundaries and the push the envelope
of the last file file system storage
file system because we're gonna be
hitting it from multiple angles with a
lot of reads and a lot of Rights and a
lot of data and a lot of activity and
you'll see that throughout the demo and
throughout some of the some of the
presentation here but what we're going
to talk about today we're gonna give you
first an overview of alastu file and
let's but first let's pose the question
and look at there we are look at what
the problems are that we're dealing with
today and there's a few slides here that
indicate the growth and the explosion of
content out there and when we talk about
content in this case we're talking about
visual effects film but any type of
content creation like commercials VR
generation and delivery as well as
streaming and transcoding you know
there's a lot of workloads around that
and one example here is just looking at
the number of shots compared to about 20
years ago in Titanic compared to a new
film like Avengers 10x the amount of
shots but if you think of
the content of the shots it's not just a
ship jumping out of the water and
breaking in half and with a few fluid
simulations if anybody's seen Avengers
it is just every single shot is just
full of hundreds of thousands of
individual assets possibly you know tens
of millions or billions of points in
terms of fluid dynamic simulations or
dust or explosions or debris simulations
and all that needs to be stored and all
that needs to be computed but if we
focus in on one aspect of of what we're
going to talk about today which is
rendering rendering is just for those of
you who are not familiar with it it's
the process of taking how do you define
rendering in one one sentence is the
process of taking a 3d set in an
environment and characters and assets
and textures and generating an image a
still 2d 2-dimensional image out of it
and remember that films are made up of a
bunch of frames and each the playback at
24 frames per second and each frame
might take minutes or hours or even days
to render there's one example some some
frames from Pixar's inside out took up
to 33 hours to render a single frame
it's insane and that's just one
iteration artists tend to iterate over
and over so they have all these
strategies for sort of faking it and
making it seem like a lot you know like
they'll do low res or they'll do low
quality and then they'll just you know
only crank up the quality at the end but
that's a 33 hour render but then when
you think about the total number of
compute hours required to generate
everything in a whole film
you know 172 thousand frames is many
many core hours you know over 5 million
core hours and again that's only if you
render at once you know typically
artists will iterate over and over until
they get something that until oh my kids
yeah I mean Pixar is pretty crazy
because they render everything in frame
that means that every shot is theirs
there's a smaller amount of things being
done but other films like Avengers
they'll render individual elements like
the character will be rendered
separately from the background so those
are separate renders and separate
processes so how do you handle all that
data and how do you how do you farm it
out to your render farm we partnered
with so
picture image works - open source their
cue management system queue management
system is essentially a job manager that
us and a scheduler that can push out
data and keep track of resources and
feed jobs to individual resources on a
very strict dependency type scale so
that you've got jobs that are dependent
on other jobs that need to finish before
this job starts at cetera et cetera
that's what a queue manager is really
good at so Sonia Imageworks developed
this over the last 15 years and they
partnered with us to open-source it so
we've stripped out all of their work
with them to strip out their proprietary
or other external dependencies and it's
available for free on github and there's
documentation online now the reason I'm
mentioning this is because the
presentation after this not here we'll
talk about it I'll show you where to go
afterwards is a deeper dive into open
queue if you're interested so stay tuned
alright so I'm going to oh we're going
to talk about
yeah that's rescue ones at 9:00 ticket
yeah yeah sorry we're just we by the way
Yannick and I just spent four days in
Las Vegas at NAB so National Association
of Broadcasters so we have the Vegas
voice and and you know we're you know
we're all cool and and worked out so
when you think about like when we talk
about legacy storage architecture I want
to look at what's hitting the shared
file server which you see in the middle
and in this type of workload and so
there's artists workstations and we're
not talking about anything on the cloud
right now we're just talking about
everybody with a you know a really
expensive workstation under their desk
and they're loading files and their
reading and writing assets and they're
talking to their asset management
database and they're deploying jobs to
things like the render workers and
render farms can typically depending on
the size of the company I think like
WeDo which is in New Zealand which does
the Hobbit films and and all the Lord of
the Rings films they have one of the
largest render farms in the world I
think it's something in the order of
120,000 cores right so obviously you
know each machine each blade is made up
of you know many of those few of those
cores and with the eight cores or 16
cores but you've got thousands of render
workers
hitting storage at the same time and in
renders render workloads typically
they'll at the start of the of the
process they'll read a whole bunch of
data into memory and then they'll sit
there and compute in memory and then
they'll when they're finished they write
a finished rendered frame which gets
written back to the disk now that's just
for render if you think about things
like liquid simulations or fluid dynamic
simulations those are generating cache
data and that's every frame they're
generating you know possibly gigabytes
or even terabytes of data which is you
not unique across different workloads
because if you think about sort of
scientific visualization and oil and gas
exploration they'd also generate massive
amounts of the simulation cache data
that could in turn be read by the people
on the workstations or by the render
farm there's a lot of transfer going
back and forth in the olden days you
know back when I had hair we had
multiple facilities that needed to
synchronize between on-prem locations
possibly around you know around the u.s.
or possibly even across across to the UK
or to Asia so there's a lot of transfer
and sync data coming in and out there
and finally if you've got you know lots
of assets and lots of production data to
to manage you're gonna need some sort of
management database and that may not be
reading and writing massive amounts but
it's just many hundreds or thousands of
QPS
queries per second that is hitting the
storage - to do things like file
comparisons and asking you know it has
this file changed since the last time it
was it was read and maybe there needs to
be some sort of front-end cache there so
to summarize you need scalability and
durability also don't forget you need to
provide things like snapshots so that
and I've done this before I've
accidentally deleted a file on a Linux
system there's no trash folder in the
Linux on a Linux workstation so how do
you get that file back you can go into
the snapshot folder and pull it back
right yeah done that countless times but
then you also need to think about
archive what's happening at the end of a
film is they'll they'll sort of clean
the whole all of the assets up and and
make sure to get rid of any data that
they don't need and then they'll archive
it and they might need to restore it at
some point
if they've got like a sequel of a film
that they'll need to pull an existing
asset down so that needs to be highly
available and easy to find and
and searchable disaster recovery as well
and a lot of customers are concerned
about regional regionalization of
disaster recovery they want somewhere
completely outside of the existing
region we'll talk about that you know in
a bit and snapshotting we talked about
earlier but there's also synchronous
sync mechanisms as well and it gets a
little deeper into the the notion of
multiple facilities that need access to
the same data that are too far apart for
both sides to read the same storage so
you can have multiple storage appliances
all synchronizing together that's an
important feature as women migrate did
mighty grating data from on-prem
supports more hybrid workflows so if
you've got on-prem infrastructure and
you're still using it and you want to
burst to the cloud for example you need
a way to get the data from on-prem to
the cloud efficiently and selectively so
that you could then render frames for
example on the cloud and then of course
cost you know how much do you want to
spend and how performant do you need it
to be and what kind of data egress are
you looking at egress of course the data
that you need to take out of the cloud
in this case we're not going to take any
data out of the cloud but if you need to
take the rendered frames and write them
back to your on-prem you need to
consider how what mechanism is doing
that so enter alastu file awesome
thank you thanks Adrian so good
transition we're gonna focus a little
bit more into the storage so the storage
in Google is going to be the backend to
all those operations right doing the
rendering doing the fluid simulation so
you will need a storage that can scale
that's fast that's secured and all the
good stuff right so we're gonna gonna go
into a little bit of details not too
crazy details because we could spend
hours going into you know size of blocks
and things like that but reading a high
level of what it is and at the end
you'll see I'll have a bunch of links so
that you can you know launch a quick lab
or go to marketplace and be be launching
edit yourself and and test it so who's
the last eval first so we're worse off
the company call that was fine and in
2013 we have offices here in the US in
the Bay Area and Santa Clara the HQ
color is in tel-aviv so that's where all
the R&D is and we have a presence in
Europe as well in London
we're really a team of storage experts
we have deep expertise into distributed
system optimizing applications and you
know I ops and throughput and all the
good thing and we've been a Google
partner for a quite a bit now and it's
been a blast radius R its really been
very good for us next
last define in one sentence it's pretty
easy at the end Elysee founde
is the scale of mass for the car so it's
a scarab mouse for google most of all
not all of you but some of you I guess
use ice alone are NetApp or filers on
tram so it's what that is but in Google
so it's going to give you file access
NFS file access for your applications to
run in a cloud so the cool thing with
that is that you can migrate and move
your traditional kind of like legacy
applications to the cloud today and when
you do rendering when you do you know
fleet emulation when you do even we did
some tests with with Adobe premier all
those applications talk NFS and file
system none of them talk s3 or the other
object protocols so you don't have to
refactor your application to bring them
to the cloud it's there it scales and
you'll see that it's supported in pretty
much every region where gcpd is so it's
a software-only
so the cool thing with that is that you
can install it in all the regions where
GCP is variable and we take advantage of
all the new features that those guys are
going to cut with come up with new discs
new versions of the instances with
better CPU and all that we don't depend
on machines that you have to install in
data centers it's all using GCP
resources right so right off the door
all the instances that those guys are
going to come up with I'm gonna be
usable on our side
it's plastics and effects right so
Google NFS protocol that you know know a
pre factoring so you bring your app into
GCP you launch an instance Linux machine
and you install a blender you know
rendering application you mount the
elastic file via NFS and you're good to
go
you put your data in and you can start
rendering it gives you a global
namespace so if you yo see at the end
we're gonna announce like around 3,000
nodes on the on the cluster so it's
going to shake it a little bit and all
those applications are going to use the
same
name space so you don't have any
limitations into creating multiple
smaller volumes and having to manage all
that that crazy you know number of
volumes it scales so today if you go on
marketplace and you'll see that we have
a managed service as well you can start
in you know just a couple of terabytes
and scare it crazy
you could go multiple petabytes and you
know as big as you want and shake it
back whenever you don't need it anymore
and it has a whole bunch of enterprise
features that are pretty cool snapshots
we did you compression will go into
details or a bit about tearing to cloud
storage so you don't want to leave your
your data on to the fast and a fest here
once you don't use it so we have a
cheering mechanism where you're going to
be able to create policies to move down
to on to cloud storage in in a nutshell
really a high level of the of the
architecture so the elastic long fast
system is going to be really the the
cloud fast system into GCP it comes with
some of the modules as well to be able
to do move contents between your own
pram or other clouds to GCP and do the
cheering so Cloud Connect is gonna be
the module that you can use its data
mover right so it can read pretty much
anything through NFS and move it to
cloud storage in in Google and then
won't once you're ready to you know to
add to work with your applications in
the cloud you're going to be able to
move that to kind of like hydrate the
NFS layer for your applications to use
to use the content on on on NFS so
elasti file is going to be installed on
the google instances and it's going to
take advantage of the different types of
disks that you have in instances local
this is these PD SSDs and standard PDS
depending kind of like on what kind of
configuration you want what kind of
performance you want out of the storage
as well okay you can access it through
restful api as well to say hey i want to
create a volume i want to be able to do
a sync between two clusters it's there's
a rich very rich api underneath that
allows you to you know script it and
write some code around the application
so we'll go a little bit into more
details about different modules and i'll
give you some examples of the
architectures that we support with those
those types of modules either so really
when we start to work with that and
define
what we're gonna do during the demo
there's two types of architecture when
it comes to burst and and move some in
media content to the cloud and compute
you have an hybrid architecture so some
of your contents is well it's on pram
all right you have your Nast or you have
whatever is a non-prime and you want to
be able to move it to the cloud launch
your cluster and be able to compute and
get it back so this is kind of like a
typical architecture you would see with
li st power cloud connect between your
local mass and cloud storage in google
in so you can transfer data in the
meantime after before that it doesn't
matter you can quickly announce an
elastic our cluster and you'll see later
on that you can do it from marketplace
as a managed service and something like
terraform which we support terraform as
well whenever you're ready you hydrate
on the NFS IDE you compute and then you
can bring it back on Prime whenever you
finish with it so it's really a burst of
your compute to the cloud you push it to
the cloud you compute and you bring it
back on on time another pretty cool
architecture as well as and this is
really what we're going to demo at the
end of a session is a virtual studio so
you're building a full partition
environment in the cloud and what you
have reading on your laptop and on your
machine is just super light client like
a Tara DG client for example that is
super organized for graphical workflows
and your Adobe stations your rendering
stations and all the the compute for the
media is going to be installed in a
cloud and taking advantage of that of
elastic file and the backend underneath
to be to be able to compute all that
stuff so it's the really the main
difference is that in that situation you
don't really transfer much stuff into
the cloud it's already there or you it's
been transferred before and you're going
to be able to work pretty much from
anywhere on your own your content in the
cloud alright so again without going too
crazy into the details
inositol is going to be able to support
not his own and not your region's right
away so again everywhere GCP is
available we're available
multi-zone means that at the top you
have your applications all the different
render nodes they go through a load
balancer to write all the different
contents onto the storage nodes at the
bottom and those can be installed on
different regions so we do multiple
copies of the data into
example in West one where a B and C so
that if one of the regions becomes
available you your application will
still be able to access the data through
the load balancer on to another region
alright and it's gonna be transparent
for the application similar to that is
the multi region so you can do it deeper
so what I forgot to mention is that in
the multi zone you do a sync copy of the
data so when one of the render node
writes data it's going to be
acknowledged when or when all the copies
are going to be written into the
different zones with multi region this
is going to be an async replication into
a different zone for a DR mirror right
you have a partition you have a mirror
somewhere just in case the in axis and
in that example west west becomes west
one because unavailable you can quickly
switch to central one and continue you
compute and you work on to a different
region and that's done in an elastic
band through the managed the management
console clear tier is really that module
that allows you to do tearing between
your elastic film fast NFS layer and
cloud storage in google and it can be
manual or it can be done through
policies that you define typically hey
all the files then on the NFS layer that
haven't been touched in the last three
hours for example move it to cloud
storage and a very cool thing is that
it's going to be transparent to the
application it's gonna be present in the
namespace
if the fans on the NFS layer or the
object layer same thing for the
application whenever it reads it it's
going to read it from either cloud
storage or NFS depending on where the
file has been has been positioned so
it's pretty cool to kind of like reduce
the cost of the infrastructure and be
able to move some of that content to
cloud storage and even for you know use
cases such as I don't know OTT streaming
content distribution using applications
that are gonna use object storage for
example and protocols object protocols
can't connect we can have like talked
about it already it's a it's really a
data mover that allows you to move
content in GCP from your own pram or
from another cloud and it's going to do
a diff sync so you can do the first sync
of your files it's going to move
everything in cloud storage and when you
have files changing on Prime
you do a new new new sink it's going to
move on only the fans that have been
changed or added or modified you don't
things like that okay and it's going to
do compression indeed you better go find
the files to a club
excuse me to that storage I think the
last one on the features is the we
talked about you mentioned that the
snapshot is really important whenever
you want to protect your data right so
we do support snapshots we have our
snapshot mechanism to disk and to GCS
and what's pretty cool is that in many
you know enterprise storage that you
would see not going to name you want but
usually what they do is that they
reserve a space on your chair one
storage to put the snapshots and that's
what it is
right like 10 percent 30 percent of the
storage the German storage can be
reserved from the snapshot with the last
define it's going to be a little bit
different you can take a snapshot leave
it to this for long enough time that you
define and then it moves to GCS so that
you don't consume it your own storage
with what it snapshots just taking a
look at the time here we just announced
last week a managed service in Google
that which is the service that have been
in beta since the the end of last year
managed service means that it's going to
be fully embedded in Google in the UI in
the billing and you're going to launch
it as you would launch a classic wall or
a bigquery or you know things like that
so in a matter of just few steps and few
clicks you launch an elastic power
cluster and you get an NFS mount point
at the end and IP and a shared volume
volume that you can mount and use on
your application and that's pretty cool
because underneath it's all gonna be
managed by Google and LSE file so you
don't even see the instances in in a
console in a Google console just to give
you an idea of the pricing of that it
will go from 10 cents a gig per month up
to 30 cents a gig per month so we have
three different models really the
difference between the three models are
the performance that you require for
your applications and it comes with you
know different types of clusters or the
minimum size of the cluster you can
answer is going to be a little bit
different right so if you need super you
know high-speed performance you would go
to the performance optimized and if you
need you know a little bit less you
would go have a tendency to go to the
capacity optimized for your for your
apps three ways to deploy alas defined
today really from the marketplace so you
go there you do a search on a last file
and then you launch it as an unmanaged
service meaning you're gonna see the
instances it's up to you to add
instances at capacity you can do it
through a managed service that we just
launched GA this week but it's been
better for for quite a while where it's
gonna be super super easy for you in a
few click to launch it and we've been
doing some work with terraform as well I
think there's gonna be a link at the end
on that as well like a QR code we we did
a tutorial to launching a cluster adding
capacity shrinking the cursor and
deletes the cluster simply with a
terraform script so we're going to take
a look at a little bit of that in the
inner demo as well but we have many
different ways well many friends we have
a native GUI in in Alaska file for you
to take a look at you know CPU
utilization throughput I ups etc etc
because you want to track what's going
on in the cluster if you have a I don't
know a client that is using all the
bandwidth or if you have a node that is
that went down so all that stuff is
going to be monitored into into a
lasting farm for you know logging for
audit for being able to monitor the
resources reporting any specific issue
to onto an agent detect anomalies like
the disk went down it's gonna give you
alerts and all the good stuff that you
would do you would you would see in a
new UI all that is gonna be in the last
you file but then on top of that and
we'll take a look at that in the demo a
little bit as well we have graph on our
templates and we set up the stack driver
as well so that you can have a little
bit of a different and deeper view of
the stats like you know how many clients
what's the client that it is using the
most many weights how many connections
you have at the same time to the cluster
so it's enriching the net a velocity
file GUI with more you know monitoring
elements into into into GCP last but not
least before we go to the demo we just
to give you an idea of the performance
of such a cluster right because we we
talk about rendering and editing and all
that so to be able to do that you
to be able to you know deliver
throughput and I UPS on to on to on to
the storage so we worked a lot with
Google on doing some some tests on
different clusters here so one is based
on the p/e SSDs and other one is based
on local SSD in standard PD you will see
that the second one has got a dual or
application yes because it's using local
SSD
and the local SSD whenever you lose the
instance you lose the data so we do
multiple copies on different instances
so that one if it happens you don't lose
the data okay so we're not gonna go too
crazy into the details of you know which
one is the best and things like that but
really to give you a high-level view of
what it can deliver take a look for
example at the throughput with the
weather read for on a four node
configuration you you will get around
you know three gigabytes per second of
throughput and if you if you move that
to 30 32 nodes it's kind of reach nearly
17 gigabytes per second meaning what
meaning that the system is really going
to scale in in capacity when you add
nodes but it's going to scale in
performance as well and in a near linear
fashion right
same for the I UPS you can see the four
nodes is gonna need deliver 96k i ups
and up to 760 k-cups onto a 32 node
configuration with PD SSDs now if you
move to local access this is gonna be
faster the local says these are gonna be
much faster than the the the SSD PD but
again it comes with having to do
multiple copies on different nodes to be
able to sustain you know losing an
instance for example but look at the
throughput here on to a 32 node for the
read and write the read typically you're
reaching nearly 29 gigabits per second
on on the cluster so you can do a lot of
stuff with that rendering and editing
and and all the good stuff show don't
tell sticker ducats all that tell
English yeah if they could who can lead
the real stuff all right so my first I'm
going to show you a short video that we
did last next if anybody was here you
might remember what we call the robot
dance party
so this is a one-minute animation that
we did as part of what's called a
virtual studio or the cloud studio we
did this at next over the three days of
the show we actually had artists working
on virtual workstations at the show in
the booth doing things like you know
animating these robots and lighting them
and texturing them and rendering them
all totally on the cloud everybody had
what's called a zero client on their
desk and a couple monitors keyboard
mouse tablet and they were all working
out of a different data set some in LA
some in Oregon and there was even one
artist working out of LA who was doing
like a video chat you could if you there
was a blog post about this it was a lot
of fun so we're gonna use these assets
in to show some of the capabilities of
the last two file and I'm going to
connect to a virtual workstation I'm
just on my laptop here I've got a piece
over IP client that I'm gonna a software
client that I'm going to log in to my
virtual workstation here and this is
located in our LA data center which is I
didn't tech this thing I think it's
probably from the convention center from
here it's probably like I think 25
milliseconds or something but I'm
running a standard Linux workstation
running since 7:00 and I've got these
scene files here and I'm running an
application called Maya if anybody's
familiar with that it's just it's one of
the sort of the main applications 3d
application packages out there that it's
very heavily used in the effects and
animation and here we've got all the
animation that's already been baked and
everything there's tons of assets in
this scene like I was mentioning earlier
there's each of these robots is a
separate asset that has separate
animation as an asset and then on the
all the pieces of the set and the
environment and the lighting and all the
texturing and everything that's all
separate but it's all combined into one
scene and rendered through you know in a
single frame so let's look through the
main render camera and we'll choose a
frame I think this guy's name is these
two robots that are named Fred and
Ginger I think this is Fred and so we're
gonna click the click the render button
and I'll show you how sort of elaborate
and complicated the process is so this
is going to render a single frame and
you'll see that it blipped a little bit
that's because it's calculating
Chandler's calculating where the shutter
opens and where the shutter closes to
use sort of a metaphor of an actual film
film camera but so it's it's doing a
whole lot of computing of the scene
right now
and it's it's gonna build that's we're
rendering into an application or in a
renderer called v-ray IV raised by a
company called Kaos group and we're
pretty closely partnered with them they
have a actually they have something
called Kaos clatter with a V right cloud
which runs on GCP it's a render farm as
a service there's a lot of this by the
way you could see there's a there's a
demo pod at the show and I think that
there's no it's like a small media
section yeah I actually haven't been
there it's got a nice noise but they
have the same Center have the same
setups if you want to dive deeper into
this you can I want to see where this
where this render is at so I'm gonna go
and open my so it's it's actually
rendering oh there's a I've got the
window behind there we are so anyways
it's it's performing a render right now
and you can see it's it's working in the
background
I actually didn't pop open the the the
render viewer but there we are so it's
running this render and it's it's
prepared all that data but it's only
rendering it inside this one square so
just to give you an idea of how
complicated and compute intensive
rendering a single frame is it's still
not finished and you can see it's sort
of iterating over and over it's called a
progressive renderer so these frames by
the way they take I think the final
frames some of them took either you know
from between 20 and 60 minutes to render
depending on what the content is some
frames are faster because you have less
in the frame some take longer because
maybe there's more motion blur motion
blur typically requires more compute
power because it's got a it's gotta
interpolate between all the motion of
the animation anyway so that's one frame
and not even a whole frame and that's
how long it took and it was actually
pretty low resolution so when it comes
time to render the whole sequence
remember this is a sequence of frames I
can grab the time slider and slide
through the the light through the
duration of the shot if I'm gonna send
that to a render farm we're gonna use
something called open cue which is like
I was mentioning earlier so I'm just
going to just quickly add a couple names
here but I'm going to define a few
variables here I'm gonna default layer
choose a camera to render
usually you have these pre-populated but
of course I don't and I'm gonna select
my start and end frames we'll do like
five frames 522 740 for example and I
can leave pretty much everything else
there what what one important thing is
what's called this chunk size that's how
many frames to render per job that gets
deployed so when I'm done I'm just gonna
my screen resolution has changed since
the last time I ran this I'm gonna click
Submit and it's saying job's submitted
so now I can go to what's called a queue
commander and look at all the jobs under
the queue commander and open
sorry not know I just quit oh I didn't
mean to do that I'll just relaunch it
cute commander launched the queue GUI
and this is where I could start to see
all of my here there's the job that I
just submitted if I double click that
these are all my frames that have been
queued up
alright so pretty simply we just queued
up hundreds of frames and they're all
organized and managed and and they're
all reading off the elastic I'll so all
that data by the way this virtual
workstation has the elastic file mounted
under the slash projects namespace right
so everything is hitting that slash
projects mount point that volume
including all the render workers and
everything else so this is one job and
that's great but I'm just one person
what if I was a whole studio what if I
was a whole hundreds of artists working
in a studio well I can deploy many
thousands of jobs to sort of
artificially fake the workload of a
studio out there and you can see I've
got three managed instance groups each
with a thousand render workers in them
and I'm going to deploy I've got a
script that will deploy hundreds and
hundreds of jobs and just fill up the
farm instantly so it's I actually forget
it he renders oh no I'm forgetting the -
project all - - project sorry equals all
so watch this you're gonna see a whole
bunch of jobs getting launched you might
see a couple like Alembic errors or
something because it's just substituting
there he goes you could ignore those but
this is all just
submitting these jobs and while these
are being submitted now we can watch
look at this we've got all these jobs
just being queued up and the farm is
being stuffed full of all these all
these tasks so each job you could see is
you know consists of hundreds of frames
for example you could just reload and
you could see there's all these
different jobs and this is a wide
variety of jobs so right now is actually
probably a good time to go and look at
it look at the cluster it look at the
cluster itself so I'll let you take over
and go through some of those some of the
monitoring tools so okay so we're going
to be connected we're connected to the
the cluster so the elasti far cluster
right now so that's what the GUI looks
like there's gonna be lots of you know
different things in there and we're not
gonna go into details of all of those
but we have a bunch of data containers
that have been created this is you know
for some of the tools that we use for
those render nodes this is the main one
the ecfs render so it's a there's not
crazy amount of data to on the on the on
the volume right now but for each of
those you know container you can set
soft corals and out corals as well for
you know NFS quotas on those shares
you're also going to be able to define
you know if you want to do snapshots if
you want to be able to do you know
cheering to objects we haven't set it up
here to be able to you know move data to
the to the cloud storage but this is
something that would you do you would do
in here you want to do deep compressions
you know things like that okay on the
main window here we will probably and
you go you will see a peak of you know
content coming in so it means that we're
seeing now all the jobs that have been
now at the same time I don't know how
many jobs you know shits or all of those
well there's like I'm gonna reading
twenty-something jobs but each job has
hundreds of frames sub jobs see this for
example this is gonna track the number
of connections that you have on a
cluster at the same time so we have a
lot of clients each of them mounting the
elastic on NFS volume at the same time
so they're all reading and writing that
content on
Krauser at the same time it's climbing
as well yeah it's kind because the the
the processes are running and gain
getting kicked so you can see here that
the the the cluster is getting hammered
a little bit with you know throughput
and I ops we're around you know 1.2 you
know gigabits per second during all the
work that we didn't do to do that demo
on that three node cluster because it's
only a three node cluster we went to
about about 2.3 or 2.2 gigabytes per
second read for you know thousands and
thousands of processes running at the
same time on the cluster right so this
is gonna give you a nice you know view
of the cluster but if you want a little
bit more you know deeper details on
what's going on graph anna is a good
example strike divert a stack driver is
also a good way to take a look at what's
going on and statistics on the cluster
graph anna typically will give you you
know information on latency number of i
ups this is something that you set up
we're gonna give you some templates to
be able to see that but see for example
yesterday night you were you know not
sleeping and playing with that stuff you
launched massive amounts of nodes and at
a point we have we had 3,000 clients
running on the same time on the cluster
and we we we actually reached around you
know 1.6 or 1.7 eight gigabytes per
second read throughput on a cluster
right so this is gonna be very useful
for you to take a look at what's going
on if you want a little bit of a deeper
look on the client that are connected on
to the cluster which one is using what
which one is using throughput or eating
all your bandwidth and things like that
you're going to be able to do that
through stackdriver and be able to track
the activity on all the different
clients that are running onto onto the
cluster which are right now i don't know
how many we have right now how many
connections but just yeah we're climbing
so it's it's launching a lot of stuff on
a cluster right and and again we don't
have time to go into the crazy details
but this is going to give you as well
here the the nodes actually the v has
the storage nodes that are used for for
the the rendering so the load balancer
on top of the on top of last eva is
going to fully manage fully balanced the
rotor of all the different come to
process on the three nodes so it's going
to distribute that onto reading and
writing onto multiple disks into into
the cluster
and you can see here some of the
information of you know how much a node
is gonna give you in terms of
performance on the on the cluster other
things yeah couple other things that are
already running are there that are that
are running right now so remember I
mentioned fluid simulations well I've
got a massive ultra mem machine with 160
V CPUs running five concurrent fluid
sims that you'll see I'll show you in a
second but this is all just writing the
data again to the elastin file cluster
right to the same namespace as
everything else and I'm able to on my
virtual workstation directly read that
data this is the results of that fluid
simulation and reading that data live
off the ecfs and these are about 24 25
million points
so obviously you can't scrub in real
time just because it's it's it's got a
load all the data frame by frame but
it's it's hitting it pretty hard to be
able to visualize all this information
and then in turn I can use a different
application like Maya to render all that
day excuse me so this virtual
workstation has obviously GPU attached
it's got one of our new Nvidia T the
touring class GPUs the t4 and that's
that enables me to render in certain
renderers which are GPU capable so I can
render this scene by going into this
v-ray IPR here and there's gonna render
on the locally locally on the GPU again
all this data is stored on the elastic
I'll all that that mesh data that you
saw there earlier and all the animation
so this is rendering on on a single t4
so it's really hammering that GPU that's
the local t4 but a t4 GPU but I've got
an entire I could have an entire cluster
of GPUs as well and v-ray has the
ability to to distribute its render
workload to multiple machines that all
have GPUs attached so if I turn on
distributed rendering I can connect to
all these machines in as part of my my
as part of my GCP project and each of
those machines is has four GPUs attached
as well so this is addressing a total of
40 GPUs these are all reading and
writing to the last
classroom again because they all just
have the same mount points it's just a
POSIX file system all these using four
minutes of shared cluster it's just a
POSIX file system that they mount NFS
and what this is what this is doing is
whereas if I already P yeah so you can
see it's connecting to all those remote
machines and give it a second it'll
there we are so now we're rendering on
40 GPUs you could see it's a lot faster
when it's humble around and this is an
interactive scene I could tweak the the
shading add lights change the the the
time everything and and it'll just
resolve so this is sending a lot of data
and it's hitting the last file really
really hard trying to absorb and
slurping all this data into memory so
that it can compute it across all this
GPUs and in on the display here so let's
go back to the presentation here because
I think we're you know we're in the
homestretch here
yes let's look at what you just saw what
the architecture of this demo that you
just saw were we have all these render
workers we have all these similar kurz
and they're all hitting the Alaska file
but we're literally writing gigabytes of
cache files to these you saw that
hundred and sixty V CPU ultra mem
machine we're writing each frame is
writing about I think 20 or 30 gigs per
simulation and it's times five so that's
being written written concurrently we've
got up probably climbed to three
thousand connections now that's actually
got more connections because of all the
the render work or the the GPU render
workers and then we're visualizing this
we've got a virtual workstation and you
could have an entire an entire facility
full of people full of artists on
virtual workstations all hitting the
same storage appliance which is pretty
impressive and so yeah let's talk about
yeah sure so what's next
that's for you guys to be able to take a
look at that and test it and there's
different ways you could you could you
could use to play with
we built a solution Google to be able to
like I said before it's relaunch our
cluster with terraform so in just you
know changing few variables in Twitter
from script you can launch a cluster a
minimum cluster add some nodes so add
capacity and performance and then shrink
the cluster whenever you don't need all
those knows anymore because you had a
peek into rendering you can shrink it
back to it
configuration and deletes the cluster
whenever you don't need it anymore
you'll be able to announce it from
marketplace as well like I said before
non-managed unmanaged so it's gonna be
really up to you to add instances or you
know shrink the cluster yourself if you
want a full manage experience with the
the gtp console we have that as well and
something that went G this week so we're
pretty happy about it
you're gonna have really the elasti file
in the console itself right and in the
matter of a few clicks you're gonna be
able to launch it and I encourage you as
well to take a look at the quick lab and
maybe you familiar with with that you
know complete call quick lab for you
know building some labs we built two
labs one on launching a small as elastic
our cluster get familiar with it this is
really a cool one as well we don't want
with blender to do a rendering in quick
lab so what's really cool with quick lab
is that it's going to build the entire
Google console environment for you the
project it's gonna give you you know the
user and all that good stuff so play
with it
so if you want to learn more about open
cue your you know want to hightail it to
the Moscone Center breakout room for a
bit of run though or my colleague
Brennan Doyle and Greg Denton will be
doing a deeper dive in open cue and
finally there is a new entry to our
cloud marketplace by Nvidia and video
now has a deployable virtual workstation
that's somewhat managed in that it takes
care of all the driver installation and
updates and everything for you so that
is leveraging the t4 which is our latest
GPU there's also we also offer p4 and P
100's
[Music]